[Musica]
[Applauso]
giusto
sto bene ho visto che le cose riferito
in uno schermo adesso che dal vivo so
cosa sia peggio
non capisco sono cose peggiorano le cose
la pasta orribile l'americana bentornati
a una nuova puntata di cucina buttata
oggi faremo un qualcosa di horror una
pasta orribile americana piatto che non
so da conte persone che è stato
consigliato su instagram che mi hanno
linkato un video presente sulla
piattaforma
in poche parole la merz questo canale
abbiamo provato tantissime cose la
carbonara francese tanta tanta tanta
altro a me è proprio quando le persone
pensavano che avessimo toccato il fondo
noi ci siamo resi conto che potevamo
ancora scappare ecco perché vi do il
benvenuto nella mia cucina sono molliamo
scilla e non so assolutamente che cosa
sto facendo questo abominio che mi avete
consigliato di fare consiste nel
cucinare la pasta cruda insieme alle
salse tutto in una teglia all'interno
del forno volevate che provassimo
qualcosa che varibile ben chi non ha
voglia di un attacco di diarrea fischio
per fare l'orribile pasta americana
avremo bisogno di 500 grammi di
spaghetti un quarto di tazza di olio di
oliva giusto per capirci le misure su
tutte americane quindi avrete bisogno di
questi tre spicchi d'aglio riguarda
l'italia una tazza di cipolla ak fonio
origano rigano 14,2 tassi di sugo già
pronto anche allo stesso di brino
identico tazze d'acqua e non ci credo
che stiamo parlando in questo nuovo le
sale pepe mozzarella brutta amicis e una
tazza ancora più grande per vomitare
anche mia
lo ricomporremo per farlo avere oppure
lasciamo con la vita a questa casa cade
a pezzi il procedimento per fare questa
roba è spaventosamente semplice così
come anche semplice kacar la prima cosa
prendiamo una come si chiama questo una
teglia una teglia da forno terrestre
niente dice tecnica che glia va bene
prendete una teglia da forno ma non c'e
lancer che come tuo nome e non cela un
cerchietto quante volte te lo devo dire
che non c'era un cerchietto questi
capelli li tagliamo sappilo fateci
sapere quatto se volete che io tagli
capitan marco brun ma anzi mettiti
moonlight
se volete che si taglino e capisce già
vabbè ma cos'hanno in i capelli che non
va se arriviamo a tratti line
no a seconda di quanto è alto sono i
centimetri che si tolgono mamma mia mi
darai casi sono due millimetri in 20mila
like sono due centimetri
vabbè quindi non mi da incanto menale fa
schifo lo prendiamo gli stretti e sta
che gli è rimasta ridotto del paese
mancavano queste ricette n si farà il
primo e assaggiando che voi allora
dicevo un terzo di taza vi lasciamo il
link qua sotto per questa roba qui in
che comunque utile che fa sta roba in
cucina lo riempiamo d'olio io mi sento
male ma vabbè a formare questa roba è
brutto non pensate sia odio la violenza
lisi a olio origano
ok attenzione uno fa sta succedendo
però senza scena sta facendo un male o
manin fanno male
vi prego non odiato ei tre spicchi
d'aglio perché proprio loro non sanno
che cosa voglia dire mangiare leggero e
affiata sicura che se una pelle umida e
con il limite in meno in questa ma
questo come fa sta tranquillo
sinceramente pensavo che ogni mille
laiche era un centimetro almeno così se
ti prego se state guardando questo video
che avrà come tema bike ha lasciato un
lecca screzio vi supplico magari lo sai
che bella vuoi capire che ci vogliono
almeno 60.000 like per levarmi tanti
capelli il mio meno io spero che
arrivino a così tanti nike che chi dovrò
direttamente andar via lametta non ti
tiri indietro sono abbastanza tranquillo
che non ci sarà questa esplosione di
like vi voglio che vengano medie casa
scusa io racchetta sceso niente quello
non mi sembra finita
guglielmo guglielmi di particolare ce lo
sta sabotando questa per avere un'aria
meraviglie guglielmo sabotaggio i ruoli
si invertono che stampa stai facendo una
magagna che hai fatto
la coperta con a mano che hai fatto
lasciato è fatto di cosa di sbagliato o
lanciati dal balcone in culla questo ho
sbagliato io nella vita
enrico lasciano in pace anche un
silenzio mettere un argine a questa
scusa ma il pane ma chiazza dagli o
comunque seggi
pepe sale una roba da farsi venire le
ragadi agli occhi sembrano molto così a
istinto 24 zio e coach 14 5 ott
così com'è o no esageri va bene mentre
un pò di più ragazzi guardate statista
del mezzo che è un po poco c'è un po di
più ma perché sta facendo questo da solo
e uno di nando una ricetta ora giardi
una cappa di sugo già pronto a ecco che
cosa faceva il volume è già ne sa
mettere più di moda che non era pieno di
elmo sei un anarchico cipolla una
capsula nelle mettiamo una anche sì
perché devono parlare incappa cipolle
non ha senso una cipolla 2 cipolle una
coppa di cipolla sbaglio
tanti erano le famiglie dove deve
bombardare il video per demolire mila
cava sarà molto difficile per fargliela
vincere a loro e supplico bravo
guglielmo grave la panza di cipolla o
mio dio mamma invece che caduti peperoni
mancato è vero lo è per noi è già
sorpassato da ottime e mezzo ho scordato
di prenderlo non c'è il peperone no non
ci credo che i ragazzi ma estesa
peperone per uomo donna vicenda è
compromessa per quanto minore a manger
chiamo siamo per compromettere
ulteriormente arriva il pezzo che fa
male agli occhi e tre a sei d'acqua
guardate posso dire che me l'aspettavo
un piano che cosa la cuoci era un po
senso devo dire resto è osceno a
castagnaro in mano una mia mi sento in
colpa
mamma mia no vabbè ma sono finiti gli
ingredienti metti ce qualkosa è orribile
ma non pensavo sarebbe successo questo
non è finito ragazzi la mozzarella
la cosa positiva è che non sporchi di
tante padelle
così così ma sporchi eccesso come certi
bella arietta creativa vado a
grattugiare la mozzarella brutta certo
poverina perché dargli della brutta
perché è giusto che posso dire la cosa
che mi disgusta di meno se anche perché
copre tutto è esatto
può sembrare parmigiano bilanci bravo è
bravo
oddio per una passatina al freezer a
sarebbe stato meglio perché queste cose
passa a volo al freezer per lo più dure
e quindi più facile da grattare e ora
quanto tempo lo schiaffo in forno 45
barra 50 minuti in a vita io non so cosa
uscirà fuori preghiamo oltre la botta di
origano ancora agosto rigano messa
bruciando le narici lo tono di questa
crociata è una garanzia assaggiarlo dopo
questo momento certo ormai mi sono
sentito meno in colpa quando ho rubato
cose si è rubato ma da piccolo i ragazzi
c'è non c'è una rosea situazione in
cucina dottore grave cioè la mozzarella
già sciolta ma si vede che gli spaghetti
sono fondo p capissi in quanto manca
l'ultima mezz'ora che succede in
mezz'ora sto schifo come prosegue oddio
ma scena
manca un minuto e fatto vedere com'è
fatta una con minuto non ha un
buonissimo tore c'è l'estate origano
rimangano lì non ho un buonissimo avuta
per fare un baratto l'ontario d'origano
anche se ti voglio dire che questa era
piena per ora
un minuto di silenzio poi dobbiamo
assaggiarla cosa è andato storto che non
sai cos'è andato storto
pensare di fare questo video ce li hai
proprio deciso che volevi fallire ma non
veniva così nell'altra oddio una cosa
che non viene come la fanno vedere un
video su instagram davvero senti questo
rumore dallo scherzo è bello quando dura
poco
prende piatto prendi anche se voi a
tavoletta eccesso non puoi partire vado
io il boccone
sgradevole tutto separato sopra
croccante sotto strano veramente una
brutta esperienza dai complimenti
beh non capisco questa divisione questo
strato è staccato completamente da
questo penso che tu debba vivere video
vabbè aver assaggiato di provarla bel
boccone di crosta con sotto una nazione
io non ho paura guarda c'è pure un pezzo
di cipolla bello pronto non va bene
quindi è urgentissimo devo venire no non
puoi farlo sei caduta non c'è nessuno in
casa per nido ragazzi dico no ma è
celano
secondo me si rialza che non ti aspetti
facendo non bene non era così il vostro
poi mi fa male il dente io veramente la
palma questo e curativo per il dente
sgradevole vero dissapori ha fatto
sgradevole la parte di sopra che spezia
va cioè sembra una roba veramente strana
e sotto c'è questo cruto bollito che non
è cotta se non da meno differente da
quello che mangiamo in uno in genere si
rende la pasta più cruda ma il
fallimento un successo allora cioè una
pazza americana insuccesso americane una
vasta pur mese è una pasta italiana non
è nemmeno pasta secondo me io chiedo
scusa non solo tutti quanti voi ragazzi
ma anche a chi ha creato questa pasta
perché non meritavano questa fine lei il
genio che ha detto che chiamo tutto
quanto in forno e se genio che fa che
copriamo con questo io direi che
possiamo chiudere ci vediamo dopo domani
martedì alle 12 con un episodio del blog
mas
thomas mi sta facendo ragionare ci
vediamo martedì alle 12 con un episodio
del blog
ciao grazie per l'ordine è veramente
osceno sgradevole sgradevole per usare
un eufemismo